Let me start today by asking the question,
what is political philosophy?
Uh,
custom dictates that I say something
about the subject matter of discourse,
uh,
at at its outset.
Uh,
this in some ways it might seem a case
of putting the cart before the horse or
the cart before the course may be,
because how can you say,
how can we say what
political philosophy is in,
in advance of,
of doing it?
Uh,
anyway,
let me try to say something
that might be useful.
In one sense,
you could say political philosophy is
simply a branch or what we call a subfield
of the field of political science.
Yes.
Right.
Uh,
it exists alongside of other
areas of political inquiry,
like American government,
comparative politics and
International Relations.
Yet in another sense,
political philosophy is something much
different than simply a sub field.
It seems to be the oldest and most
fundamental part of political science.
It's purpose is to lay bare as it were,
the fundamental problems,
the fundamental concepts and categories
which frame the study of politics in
this respect.
It seems to me much less like just
a branch of political science.
Then a foundation of
the entire discipline.
The study of political philosophy,
uh,
often begins as this course will do.
Also with the study of the great books
or some of the great books of our field.
Political philosophy is the oldest of
the social sciences and it can boast a
wealth of heavy hitters from Plato
and Aristotle to Machiavelli Hobbs,
Hagle,
Tocqueville,
nature and so on.
You might say that the best way to find
out what political philosophy is is
simply to study and read the works
of those who have shaped the field.
Yes,
right.
But to do that is I recognize
not without dangers,
often severe dangers of its own.
Why study just these
thinkers and not others
isn't any so called list of great thinkers
are great texts like likely to be are
simply arbitrary and to tell us more
about what such a list excludes than what
it includes.
Furthermore,
it would seem that the
study of the great books,
great thinkers of the past can easily
degenerate into a kind of antiquarianism
into a sort of pedantry.
We find ourselves easily intimidated by
a list of famous names and end up not
thinking for ourselves.
Furthermore,
doesn't this study of old books,
often very old box risk overlooking
Lee issues facing us today?
I mean,
what can Aristotle or Hobbs tell us
about the world of globalization,
of terrorism,
of ethnic conflict and the light?
Doesn't political science
make any progress?
Uh,
after all,
uh,
economists no longer read Adam Smith,
I hesitate to,
I don't hesitate to say that a it for
you will never read Adam Smith in a,
in an economics course here at Yale.
And it is very unlikely
that you will read Freud,
uh,
in your psychology classes.
So why then does political
science apparently uniquely
among the Social Sciences
continue to study Aristotle,
Locke,
uh,
and other old books.
These are all real questions and I
raised them now myself because they are
questions I want you to be thinking
about as you do your reading and,
uh,
work through this course.
I want you to remain alive to
them throughout the semester.
Yes.
Okay.
Uh,
one reason I wanted to suggest that we
continue to read these books is not,
not because political science makes no
progress or that we are somehow uniquely
fixated on an ancient pass.
But because of these works provide
us with the most basic questions that
continue to guide our field.
We continue to ask the same
questions that were asked by Plato,
Machiavelli,
Hobbs and others.
We may not accept their answers,
and it's very likely that we do not,
but their questions are often put with
a kind of an unrivaled clarity and
insight.
The fact is that there are
still people in the world,
many people who regard
themselves as Aristotle,
Ian's Thomas Lock,
eons,
uh,
even the occasional Marxist can still
be found in the Ivy League universities.
These doctrines have not simply been
refuted or replaced or historically
superseded.
They remain in many ways,
constitutive of our most
basic outlooks and attitudes.
They are very much alive with us today,
right?
So political philosophy is not just some
kind of strange historical appendage to
the,
uh,
attached to the trunk
of political science.
I just constitutive of
its deepest problems.
If you doubt the importance of the
study of political ideas for politics,
consider the works of a famous economist,
John Maynard Keynes.
Everyone's heard of him.
Keynes wrote in 1935 the ideas of
economists and political philosophers both
when they are right and
when they are wrong,
I'm more powerful than
is commonly understood.
Practical men,
canes continues practical men who believed
themselves to be quite exempt from
any intellectual influences are usually
the slave of some defunct economist.
Madmen in authority who hear voices in
the air are distilling their frenzy from
some academic scribbler
of a few years back.
So this course will be devoted to the
study of those academic scribblers who
have written books that,
uh,
continue to impress a and
create the forms of authority,
uh,
with which we are familiar.
Okay.
But one thing we should not do,
right?
One thing we should not do is to approach
these works as if they provide somehow
answers ready made answers
to the problems of today.
Only we can provide
answers to our problems.
Rather the great works provide us so to
speak with a repository of fundamental
or permanent questions that political
scientists still continue to rely on in
their work.
The great thinkers are great not because
they've created some set of museum
pieces that can be catalog,
admired and then safely ignored like
a kind of antiquities gallery in the
Metropolitan Museum of art,
but rather because they have defined
the problems that all later thinkers and
scholars have had to use in order
to make sense of their world at all.
Again,
we still think in terms of the basic
concepts and categories that were created
for us long ago.
Okay,
so one thing you will quickly note.
is it,
there are no permanent answers.
In a study of political philosophy,
a famous mathematician
once said,
every question must have a
correct answer for every question.
One answer.
That itself is an eminently
contestable proposition.
Among the great thinkers,
there is profound disagreement over the
answers to even the most fundamental
questions concerning justice concerning
rights concerning liberty in political
philosophy.
It has never a sufficient answer to a
request to answer a question with the
estate.
With the statement because Plato
says so or because nature says so.
Uh,
there are no final authorities in that
respect in philosophy because even the
greatest thinkers disagree profoundly
with one another over their answers.
And it is precisely this disagreement
with one another that makes it possible
for us.
The readers today,
to enter into their conversation.
We are called upon first to read and
listen and then to judge who is right.
How do we know?
The only way to decide is
not to defer to authority,
whoever's authority,
but to rely on our own powers
of reason and judgment.
In other words,
the freedom of the human mind to
determine for us what seems right or best.
Okay,
but what are these problems
that I'm referring to?
What are these problems that constitute
the subject matter of this study of
politics?
What are the questions that
political scientists try to answer?
Such a list may be long,
but,
but not infinitely.
So among the oldest and still most
fundamental questions are what is justice?
What are the goals of a decent society?
How should a citizen be educated?
Why should I obey the law?
And what are the limits,
if any,
to my obligation?
What constitutes the
ground of human dignity?
Is it freedom?
Is it virtual?
Is it love?
Is it friendship?
And of course the all important question.
Even though political philosophers and
political scientists rarely pronounce it,
namely quid sit dios.
What has God does he exist and what does
that imply for our obligations as human
beings and citizens?
Those are some of the most basic and
fundamental problems of the study of
politics,
but you might say,
where did,
where does one enter this debate?
Which questions in which thinkers
should one pick up for oneself?
Perhaps the oldest and most fundamental
question that I wish to examine in the
course of this semester is the question,
what is a regime?
What are regimes?
What are regime politics?
The term regime is a familiar one.
We often hear today about shaping
regimes or about changing regimes,
but what is a regime?
How many kinds are there?
How are they defined?
What holds them together and
what causes them to fall apart?
Is there a single best regime?
Those are the questions
I want us to consider.
The concept of the regime is perhaps
the oldest and most fundamental of
political ideas.
It goes back to Plato and even before him.
In fact,
the title of the book that you will
be reading Pardot for this semester,
Plato's Republic is
actually a translation.
The title of it,
of the Greek word polar,
a Taya,
that means constitution or regime.
The Republic is a book about the regime
and all later political philosophy.
It's a series of footnotes to Plato and
that means that it must provide a series
of variations,
so to speak,
on Plato's conception of the best regime,
but what is a regime?
Broadly speaking,
the regime indicates a form of government,
whether it is ruled by the one,
the feel,
the many,
or is more common,
some mixture or a combination
of these three ruling powers.
The regime is defined in
the first instance by how
are people are governed and
how public offices are
distributed by election,
by birth,
by lot,
by outstanding personal personal
qualities and achievements,
and what constitutes that people's
rights and responsibilities.
The regime regime again refers
above all to a form of government.
The political world does not present
itself as simply an infinite variety of
different shapes.
It is structured and ordered into
a few basic regime types and this,
I take it to be one of the most important
propositions and insights of political
science,
right so far,
but there is a corollary to this insight.
The regime is always something particular.
It stands interrelation of opposition
to other regime types and as a
consequence,
the possibility of conflict of tension
and war is built in to the very structure
of politics.
Regimes are necessarily partisan.
That is to say they install certain
loyalties in passions in the same way that
one may feel.
Partisanship to the New York
Yankees or the Boston red sox.
What?
Yale overall rival
colleges and institutions,
right?
Fierce loyalty,
partisanship.
It's inseparable from the
character of regime politics.
These passionate attachments are not
merely something that take place,
you might say between different regimes,
but even within them is different
parties and groups with loyalties and
detachments contend for power,
for honor and for interest.
Henry Adams once cynically reflected that
politics is simply the organization of
hatreds
and there is more than a
grain of truth to this.
Right.
Although he did not say that.
It is also attempt and attempt to
channel and redirect those hatreds and
animosities towards
something like a common good.
This raises a question.
Is it possible to transform politics to
replace enmity and factional conflict
with friendship to replace
conflict with harmony
today is it is the hope of many people
both here and abroad that we might even
overcome,
might even transcend the basic structure
of regime politics altogether and
organize our world around global norms
of justice and international law.
It is such a thing possible.
It can't be ruled out,
but such a world I would note that
is to say a world administered by
international courts of law by judges
and judicial tribunals would no longer be
a political world.
Politics only takes place within
the context of the particular,
it is only
possible within the structure
of the regime itself,
but the regime is more than simply
a set of formal principal of formal
structures and institutions.
Okay.
It consists of the entire way of life,
the moral and religious practices,
the habits,
customs and sentiments that
make people what they are.
The regime constitutes an ethos that
is to say distinctive character that
nurtures distinctive human types.
Every regime shapes a common character,
a common character type with
distinctive traits and qualities.
So the study of regime politics is in
part a study of the distinctive national
character types that
constitutes a citizen body.
To take an example of
what I mean when talk,
they'll study the American regime or the
democratic regime properly speaking and
democracy in America.
He started first with our formal political
institutions is enumerated in the
constitution,
such things as the separation of powers,
the division between state and
federal government and so on,
but then went on to look at such informal
practices as American manners and
morals.
Our tendency to form small
civic associations are peculiar,
moralism and religious life or
defensiveness about democracy and so on.
All of these intellectual and moral
customs and habits help to constitute the
democratic regime.
This regime,
in this sense,
the regime describes the
character or tone of a society.
What a society finds most praiseworthy,
what it looks up to.
Okay.
You can't understand a regime
unless you understand so to speak,
what it stands for,
what a people stand for,
what they,
what they look up to
as well as its,
again,
its structure of institutions
and rights and privileges.
This raises a further set of questions
that we will consider over the term how,
how our regimes founded
the founding of regimes,
what brings them into being
and sustains them over time.
For thinkers like Tocqueville for example,
regimes are embedded
in the deep structures,
uh,
of human history that have determined
over long centuries the shape of our
political institutions and
the way we think about them.
Yet other voices within the tradition,
Plato,
Machiavelli,
who sell come to mind believe that
regimes can be self consciously founded
through deliberate act of great statesman
or founding fathers as we might call
them.
The statesmen.
Machiavelli for example,
refers to Romulus Moses.
Cyrus is the founders that he looks too,
we might think of men like Washington,
Jefferson Adams and the like are
shapers of peoples and institutions.
The very first of the federalist papers
by Alexander Hamilton even begins by
posing this question
and its starkest terms.
It has been frequently remarked,
Hamilton writes,
did.
It seems to have been reserved to the
people of this country by their conduct
and example to decide the
important question whether
societies of men are really
capable or not of establishing good
government from reflection and choice or
whether they are forever
destined to depend for their
political constitutions on
accident and force.
There we see Hamilton asking the basic
question about the founding of political
institutions.
Are they created as he as he
puts it by reflection and choice.
That is to say by a deliberate act
of state craft and in conscious human
intelligence or our regimes
always the product of accident,
circumstance,
custom and history.
Yeah,
but the idea that regimes may be created
or founded by a set of deliberate act
raises a further question that we will
study and is inseparable from the study
of regimes as pie.
Okay.
Who was a statesman?
What does a statesman,
again,
one of the oldest questions of political
science very rarely asked by the
political science of today that is
very skeptical of the language of
statesmanship
and its oldest sense.
Political science simply
was a science of statecraft.
It was addressed just statesmen
or potential statesmen
charged with steering the
ship of state.
What are the qualities necessary
for sound statesmanship?
How does statecraft differ
from other kinds of activities?
Must have good statesmen
as Plato believed,
for example,
be a philosopher versed in poetry,
mathematics and metaphysics,
or the statesmanship as Aristotle believed
a purely practical skill requiring
judgment based on
deliberation and experience.
It's a streak of cruelty and a
willingness to act immorally necessary for
statecraft.
As Machiavelli infamously argued,
was the statesman be capable of literally
transforming human nature as Roussel
maintains or is the sovereign a more or
less faceless bureaucrat in the manner
of a modern,
say a modern CEO,
uh,
as for example,
someone like Hobbs seems to have believed
all of our texts that we will read the
republic,
the politics,
the prince,
the social contract have different
views on the qualities of statecraft.
And what it is,
what,
what those qualities necessary to
found and maintain states that we will,
we will be considering
all of this in a way is another
way of saying or at least implying,
okay,
that political philosophy is an
imminently practical discipline.
A practical field.
It's purpose is not simply contemplation.
It's purpose is not reflection alone.
It is advice giving all of the peat,
none of that.
None of the people we will study this
semester were cloistered scholars detached
from the world.
Although this is a very common prejudice
against political philosophy that it is
somehow a uniquely sort of pie in the
sky and and detached from the world.
But the great thinkers,
we're very far from being just sort
of speak detached intellectuals.
Plato undertook three long and dangerous
voyages to Sicily in order to advise
the king guy in ics.
Aristotle famously was a tutor of
Alexander the Great Machiavelli,
spent a large part of his career in the
foreign service of his native Florence
and wrote as an advisor to the medic.
Hobbes was the tutor to a royal household
who followed the king into exile
during the English civil war and lock was
associated with the Shaftsbury circle,
who also was forced into exile after
being accused of plotting against the
English gain.
Russo had no official
political connections,
but he signed his name
always John Jacques Rousseau,
citizen of Geneva,
and was approached to write constitutions
for Poland and for the island of
Corsica.
And Tocqueville was a,
was a member of the French National
Assembly whose experience of American
democracy deeply affected the
way he saw the future of Europe.
So the great political thinkers,
we're typically engaged in the politics
of their times and help in that way to
provide us okay with models for
how we might think about ours.
Okay.
A little break for refreshment.
But this goes in a slightly
different direction as well.
Not only is this study of the regime
is we've seen as I've just tried to
indicate rooted in in many
ways the practical experience
of the thinkers will be
looking at,
but the study of regime politics either
implicitly or explicitly raises a
question that goes beyond
the boundary of any,
any given society
regime,
as I've said,
constitutes a people's way of life.
What they believe makes their life worth
living or to put it against slightly
different what people stand for.
Yeah.
Although we are most familiar with the
character of a modern democratic regimes
such as ours.
This study of political philosophy is in
many ways a kind of immersion into what
we might call today comparative politics.
That is just a,
it opens up to us the variety of regimes
each with its own distinctive set of
claims or principals,
each vying and potentially in
conflict with all the others.
Okay.
Underlying this cacophony of
regimes is the question always,
which of these regimes is best?
What has or ought to have a claim
on our loyalty and rational consent?
Political philosophy is always guided
by the question of the best regime,
but what is the best regime even to
raise a central question seems to pose in
Superbowl obstacles,
isn't that you're completely
subjective judgment.
What one thinks is the best regime.
How could one begin such a study
is the best regime as the
ancients tended to believe,
I know Aristotle and others,
is it or is it an aristocratic republic
in which only the few best habitually
rule or is the best regime?
As the moderns believe
a democratic republic,
we're in principle,
political office is open to our by virtue
of their membership in society alone,
will the best regime be a small closed
society that through generations has made
a supreme sacrifice
toward self perfection?
Think of that
or will the best regime be a large
cosmopolitan order embracing all human
beings,
perhaps even a kind of universal league
of nations consisting of are free and
equal men and women.
Whatever form the best regime takes,
however,
it will always favor a certain kind
of human being with a certain set of
character traits is that type the
common man is found in democracies.
Those of acquired taste and money is in
aristocracies the warrior or even the
priest is in theocracies.
No,
no question that I can think
of can be more fundamental.
And this finally raises the question of
the relation between the best regime or
the good regime and what we could
say are actually existing regimes,
regimes that we are all familiar with.
What function does the best
regime play in political science?
How does it guide our actions here and
now this issue re received a kind of
classic formulation in
Aristotle's distinction of
what he called the good human
being and the good citizen
for the good citizen.
You will read this chapter later on
in the politics for the good citizen.
You could say patriotism is enough to
uphold and defend the laws of your own
country simply because they are your
own is both necessary and sufficient.
Such a view of citizen virtue runs into
the obvious objection that the good
citizen of one regime will be at odds
with the good citizen of another.
A good citizen of contemporary Iran will
not be the same as the good citizen of
Contemporary America.
But the good citizen Aristotle goes on
to say is not the same as the good human
being,
right?
Or the good citizen is
relative to the regime.
You might say regime specific,
the good human being.
So he believes is good everywhere.
The good human being loves what is good,
simply not,
not because it is his own,
but because it is good.
Some sense of this was demonstrated in
Abraham Lincoln's judgment about Henry.
Uh,
in early,
uh,
idol of Lincoln's clay wrote,
Lincoln Road of clay.
He loved his country.
He said partly because
it was his own country,
partly because it was his own country,
but mainly because it was a free country.
Uh,
his point I think is that clay exhibited
at least on Lincoln's telling something
of the philosopher.
What he loved was an idea,
the idea of freedom.
That idea was not the property
of one particular country,
but it was constitute of,
of any good society.
The good human being it would seem,
would be a philosopher or at least would
have something philosophical about him
or her and who may only be fully
at home in the best regime.
But of course the best regime,
laxed actuality,
we all know that it has never existed.
Okay.
Best regime embodies a supreme paradox.
It would seem it is
superior in some ways too,
all actual regimes,
but it has no concrete existence anywhere.
This makes it difficult.
You could say,
and this is Aristotle's point,
I think this makes it difficult for the
philosopher to be a good citizen of any
actual regime.
Philosophy will never feel fully or
truly at home in any particular society.
The philosopher can never be truly
loyal to any one or any thing,
but what is best?
Think of that.
Okay.
Raises a question about issues of love,
loyalty and friendship.
This tension of course,
between the best regime in any actual
regime is the space that makes political
philosophy possible.
In the best regime.
If we were to inhabit such a political
philosophy would be unnecessary or
redundant,
it would wither away.
Political philosophy exists and
only exists in that call it zone of
indeterminacy between the is and the
art between the actual and the ideal.
This is why political philosophy is
always in necessarily a potentially
disturbing undertaking.
Those who embark on the
quest for knowledge of the
best regime may not return
the same people that they were before.
You may return with very
different loyalties and
allegiances than you had in the
beginning,
but there is some compensation for this.
I think the ancients had a beautiful word,
or at least the Greeks had a
beautiful word for this quest,
for this desire,
for knowledge of the best regime
they called it arrows or love,
right?
The quest for knowledge of the best
regime must necessarily be accompanied,
sustained,
and elevated by arrows.
You may not have realized it when
you walked into this class today,
but the study of political philosophy,
maybe the highest tribute,
we pay to love.
Think of them,
and while you're thinking about it,
you can start reading
Plato's apology for Socrates,
which we'll discuss
for class on Wednesday.
Okay.
It's nice to see you back and have a
very good but thoughtful September 11th.